-Welcome back.
-Jimmy!
-Hi.
-Look at you.
The hardest-working people
in show business.
-Oh, stop it. You are.
-You start the network
in the morning
and you're closing --
-We're shutting it down!
-Shutting it down with
"The Tonight Show."
Come on.
-Come on.
-Thank you again
for coming back.
I always love seeing you.
I watch you every single day.
You finally got a little
time off during the holidays.
-We did.
-A little break.
-Oh, my God.
-What'd you do?
-Okay, so, Jimmy,
I took my two girls,
Haley and Hope, to Universal.
-They're the cutest kids.
-First of all, they met you,
and they adore you,
so when we were
walking around, I go,
"Look -- there's
a Jimmy Fallon ride!"
-I have my own ride.
-Wait. You have your own --
Have y'all ever been on it?
It's -- Okay, it's really fun.
So, my 3-year-old
put the glasses on.
You get locked in.
It's like you're in
"The Tonight Show."
Jimmy, she was terrified.
She is, like, scarred.
-I don't think she can do that.
-She loved you, but now --
-She's too young.
-Yeah, she just --
-Did she throw up?
-She just made the height.
She didn't throw up.
-Did she understand
what was happening?
-Jimmy, she was terrified.
She kept going, "Where's Jimmy?
Where's Jimmy? No!
Get me out, get me out,
get me out!"
And you can't get out
once you're in.
-Just like "The Tonight Show."
Yeah, they're all strapped in.
They're not allowed to leave.
-By the way, it was super-fun,
but she was way too little.
But you have to, like,
come and hug her.
-Alright, next time,
bring her over.
Yeah, yeah,
I'll come by and see you.
How about -- You have
a birthday around Christmas.
-Yes, I do.
The coveted
two-days-after-Christmas
birthday, when everybody was
really in the mood to celebrate.
And, also, I turned 51,
which is so not exciting.
-Oh, my gosh. Happy birthday!
Yes! Come on.
-Yes, it is exciting.
-But my little boy asked me,
literally, the other day --
You know how,
when they're little,
they have the 4-year-old visit,
the 5-year-old visit?
My little boy goes, "Mommy,
did you have your
51-year-old visit?"
-Oh, no.
-I know.
And I was like, "Yeah,
they weighed and measured me.
I got the shingles vaccine."
Yeah, so, we did that,
and it was fun.
-It was fun?
A little family time?
Did you get any good gifts?
-You know what
the cutest thing is?
The kids actually wrote down
what they liked about me,
which is really --
-Are you joking?
-I know.
And I think they were, like,
you know, prompted to do that.
-Yeah.
-But my little boy said
I smelled good.
-Hey!
-Yes.
And my daughter said,
"She acts like a little girl"
and that I sing, but badly.
-No!
-Yes.
-Still, you take it.
That's so cute.
-Yeah.
-Come on.
Before we talk about
the five years,
I want to talk about your
new podcast.
Talk to me about this.
"Making Space."
-By the way,
I love this podcast, Jimmy.
There are certain things you do
and you're crazy about.
This whole --
This podcast is all kind of
inspirational leaders
and teachers.
-You love -- You're good at --
You love that.
-I'm so -- I'm so in.
I feel like if I wasn't doing
the podcast, like,
I would be listening to it.
But we had this lady on
named Mel Robbins,
who's a very, like --
she's a motivational speaker.
-Yeah.
-And she was saying to --
She was saying,
"Look, in the new year,
you should do --
You can start off by
this resolution."
She said,
"The very first decision
you make every morning
when you wake up,
the very, very first decision
when your alarm goes off is,
you're going to decide whether
or not you're going to
procrastinate to start your day
or you're going to hop up."
She said, "The very first
decision you make
in the morning,
never ever hit snooze.
Feet on the floor, get up,
get into the shower right away.
Make your bed right away."
And she said,
"Once you do those things --"
-I don't know.
I don't know about this.
-Jimmy, that means the whole --
-I might do the first one,
but I can't do both things.
-That's too much?
-Feels like I'm in the...
-It's a lot?
-...yeah, the armed forces.
I want to talk about
"Today," okay?
This is
a landmark show, obviously,
one of the --
"Tonight Show," "Today Show."
Recently, we lost a legend,
journalist Barbara Walters,
who was on the "Today" show
for 15 years?
-Mm-hmm.
-What did her legacy
leave behind?
What does she mean to you guys?
-Well, she -- I think she said
it best when we --
A few years ago, when she
retired from "The View,"
they invited newswomen
past and present,
and everyone walked out
and surprised her.
And, I mean,
everybody was there.
Oprah was there, everyone.
And Barbara looked around,
and she said,
"You guys are my legacy."
And I think we know
that that is true.
I mean, at the "Today" show
in particular,
we're not here without
Barbara Walters
knocking down that door
and doing it when
there was no precedent.
There was no example.
There was no representation
of that path.
She did it.
She blazed the trail
like a pioneer.
-We are able to sit and have
two women anchoring together,
which is now totally normal,
because of what Barbara did.
-Yeah, you say Barbara --
Yeah, of course.
She was a trailblazer.
But think about that.
That's five years
of doing this together.
When you first were sat together
and you opened the "Today" show,
did it feel like
a moment to you?
-It felt like a moment, but not
because it was two women.
It was because it was us.
-Yeah.
-You know, it was --
We literally held hands
and said, "Let's do this."
-"Let's go."
-You know?
-But it was a moment
for women, I would think.
-I think it was.
We didn't realize it,
because I remember,
I went to
a SoulCycle spin class
and I walked in shortly after
Savannah and I had started.
And I sat in the same seat
I always sit in,
in Sue's SoulCycle class.
And I sat in my chair,
and people started clapping.
And I was like, "Oh, my God.
Someone has a birthday."
You know, they always do --
You know how they do.
-Yeah, yeah, the bike clap.
They root for each other.
They're like, "You go!"
-"You got it! Yeah!"
-"You got it."
-"50 looks good!" Anyway...
And as I was sitting,
I was looking around,
and they were looking at me.
And I said --
I go, "What's going on?"
And they go, "What you and
Savannah did today.
It was big. It was big."
And I told Savannah --
I said, "Oh, my God.
It mattered."
Like, we didn't realize,
I think, in the moment
that it did, and now --
-Have you seen things
change since you've started?
-You know one thing
that we notice a lot?
Is in local news,
which we came up in local news,
you know, if somebody
was gone and you needed a sub,
it was always a guy and a girl.
It was always a man and a woman.
It was like Dina and Todd
or whoever and whoever.
They would never
put two women --
They would never say,
"Oh, Todd's off tonight.
Hoda, can you fill in? Savannah?
No, we can't have two women."
-Two women.
-Now we notice, because we do
all these affiliate cross-tags,
so we see it
in local news all the time.
There are a lot of
female partnerships.
So, I don't know if that's --
Probably not because of us,
but now it's just more normal.
And I think that's really cool.
-I think it is
because of you guys, yeah.
-Todd shouldn't have taken
all that time off.
-No, exactly right, yeah.
-And you know what else
is really cool?
-Yeah.
-Guess who's coming back
tomorrow, Jimmy, on our show.
-Al.
-Guess who's coming back.
-Al Roker?
-Yes!
-Al Roker's back?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We love you, Al.
No, no, no.
I'm going to lose it.
I love -- I'm going to lose it.
I love that guy so much.
-You sent him such cool videos
when he was in the hospital.
-He's such a good guy.
I can't wait.
Alright, good.
I'll try to watch --
I'll come in tomorrow early
just to say hi to Al.
-You'll have to wake up
in the morning hours.
-I won't hit snooze.
Yeah, exactly.
But, really,
I wanted to thank you for
coming on the show again,
but also to thank you for what
you're doing
and what you've done.
Five years -- this is massive,
what you're doing.
And you're the best.
I watch you every morning.
You're the greatest.
Thank you, guys, so much.
-Jimmy, we love you.
We love you.
-Savannah Guthrie, Hoda Kotb --
no one better --
right here on
the "Today" show on NBC.
We'll be right back
with Colin Quinn, everybody.
Stick around.